in 2014 a man in Caddo Parish Louisiana
is named Gary Howard was sentenced to 18
years without the possibility of parole
for possessing 18 grams of marijuana the
case recently made its way to the
Louisiana Supreme Court and was upheld
but Chief Justice Burnett Johnson called
the sentence ridiculous and castigated
her colleagues who affirmed that
sentence Howard had a past criminal
history
it included possession of a firearm by a
convicted felon but 18 years for 18
grams of pot a year per gram with no
parole for marijuana possession no
consideration for good behavior
in prison maybe getting out somewhat
earlier no consideration for
rehabilitation
during that 18 year sentence just a
cold-blooded reactionary sort of like
retribution type sentence for
non-violent drug possession and we're
talking about marijuana and he was not
caught distributing no for some people
what I've read on the internet Pat I
don't know about this but 18 grams is a
weekend for some people I wouldn't know
myself that I've read of course not it's
enough to fill the bottom of a
normal-sized plastic ziplock bag if you
lay it flat on a table it's about enough
area to cover a dollar bill but again I
researched all that I don't have
anything about that Chief Justice
Johnson said it was an arbitrary
decision to sentence him to a year
program she wrote in her dissent quote
legally the state proved nothing more
than simple possession of marijuana in
this case as a practical matter in light
of the inconsequential amount of
marijuana found imprisoning the
defendant for this extreme length of
time at a cost of about $23,000 per year
costing our state over $400,000 in total
provides a little societal value and
only serves to further burden our
financially strapped state and it's
taxpayers yes Louisiana is financially
strapped it's also a state with the
highest per capita incarceration rate in
the country and there are currently
proposed bills in the state legislature
in Louisiana that are going to try to
reduce incarceration by reforming the
habitual offender laws which would have
benefited mr.
in this situation Rob Smith who directs
the Harvard Law School's fair punishment
project said quote Louisiana law
authorizes these draconian sentences
that would embarrass its other than
southern its other southern neighbors
there's another problem I want to talk
about and this is not just in Louisiana
with intent to distribute okay that's a
charge
used throughout the country on drug
charges which is very problematic and
it's often applied arbitrarily like in
this case where there's really no proof
that the individual was going to sell
the amount of drugs that they had I
actually like an intent to distribute
Pat with resisting arrest
resisting arrest is so frequently used
disproportionately so capriciously so
with racial overtones and in so many
other discriminatory ways and intent to
distribute is similar in the drug world
to resisting arrest it's an easy charge
to add on isn't it you know it's a great
thing in the u.s. that we have these
diverse states and there's different
cultures and laws in between all of them
short but it's just crazy to me how in
some states if you're over 21 you can go
into a shop and buy marijuana right and
in other states you get 18 years for 18
grams it's a patchwork that makes
absolutely no sense we know which
direction we should be moving in
Attorney General Jeff Sessions once is
moving in the other direction to unify
marijuana law around the country and
just when you hear about this 18 years
for 18 grams something is just
fundamentally wrong with our system and
lots of people are making money on this
remember the South up particularly I'm
not saying Howard specifically will go
to a for-profit prison there are not
that many nationwide only like 9% of
prisoners are in for-profit prisons but
in certain areas they get a lot of the
really profitable sentences right you
can make money off of marijuana in two
ways if you're a state one is the
for-profit prisons and the other one is
the attacks revenues I think it's pretty
clear which one we should choose yes
especially when the tax revenues from
legalized marijuana can then be used for
public health programs education etc